I wish I had a time machine just so you
can take a ride with me
cuevo pays tribute to his late nephew
and Migo's band mate take off during an
emotional performance of his song
without you at the 2023 Grammys
back yeah
the rapper sat in front of an empty
chair and the mic that held take off
Shane as he wrapped the lyrics he was
also joined on stage by atlanta-based
gospel group Maverick City Music
[Music]
takeoff died in November after being
shot at a Houston area bowling alley
cuevo was with him on the night of his
death at the time their fellow Migos
band made offset posted a tribute to
Instagram writing quote the pain you
have left me with is unbearable you know
you get to share life-changing moments
with people who
change your life for you know what I'm
saying all our families is when we sit
together we eat together you know what
I'm saying you are affecting culture
across pop music everywhere who doesn't
understand who needs to know you know we
all need to know if you you know I'm
saying if you're part of the culture and
a part of hip-hop and music you need to
know